this is the most important road in
Afghanistan it runs from the capital
Kabul to the second biggest city con dar
it was the cornerstone of the u.s.
strategy to rebuild Afghanistan after
the invasion in 2001 it cost over 200
million dollars to build and hundreds of
lives were lost defending it despite all
of that the Kabul to Kandahar highway
today is broken a 2016 auto report found
that the road was beyond repair and
needed to be rebuilt and if it becomes
impassable the central government will
collapse to understand how a road this
significant and this costly can be
falling apart you have to ask where did
the u.s. go wrong in Afghanistan
[Music]
just weeks after 9/11 the u.s. invaded
Afghanistan where Al Qaeda had planned
the attacks they were sheltered by the
Taliban who controlled the Afghan
government at the time both groups were
driven out of Kabul in a matter of
months so the u.s. strategy soon shifted
from combat to stabilizing and
rebuilding the country but Afghanistan's
a difficult place to control and rebuild
its mountainous and mostly rural the
population is fractured among several
ethnic groups and local communities
often operated autonomously to make
matters worse there were only 50
kilometers of paved road in 2002 which
meant most of these communities were
isolated the u.s. decided to change that
by rebuilding the Ring Road that was
partially built by the Soviet Union in
the 60s but had been destroyed by
decades of war starting with the Kabul
to Kandahar section the US and several
other countries pledged 1.5 billion
dollars to the Ring Road it would run in
a 3,200 kilometer loop connecting
Afghanistan's four biggest cities
essentially tying these communities
together and it was showing promise
trade circulated through more places and
medical services reach more people it
gave the new government in Kabul more
legitimacy around the country the Ring
Road also allowed the US and NATO
military to send troops and supplies
around the country faster so they could
keep the Taliban in check for the roads
and Afghanistan the Taliban begin in
other words roads promote enterprise
Enterprise provides hope hope is what
defeats this ideology of darkness but
the u.s. didn't finish the job in 2003
the u.s. invaded Iraq and Afghanistan
became second priority funding
reconstruction resources and experienced
leadership including generals and
diplomats were all diverted to the war
in Iraq the Ring Road was far from
complete yet reconstruction funding was
cut by 1.2 billion dollars a few years
later the US preoccupation with Iraq
gave the Taliban and open to return and
they seized it when you look at the
Taliban activity in the region from 2004
through 2009 you can see it escalate
draw the Ring Road and you can see where
those activities are concentrated
instead of ambushes laid roadside bombs
took hostages killed US soldiers and
road construction crews a 2008 the
Taliban had taken back significant
territory especially in the south and
east along the Kabul to Kandahar highway
Afghanistan was in a full-blown
insurgency Afghanistan is not lost but
for several years it has moved backwards
there's no imminent threat of the
government being overthrown but the
Taliban has gained momentum in short the
status quo is not sustainable in 2009
President Barack Obama decided to
recommit to the war in Afghanistan he
sent thousands of troops in what was
called the surge the US and NATO made
some progress in the south but it
quickly became clear that the Taliban
would not be easily defeated the more
troops deployed to Afghanistan the more
the Taliban launched attacks with the
military struggling to clear territory
it became nearly impossible to rebuild
roads as the Taliban continued to attack
road crews the degraded security
environment has made this the most
dangerous project her company has
attempted since we have suffered 21
killed 51 wounded and four missing this
forced construction companies to hire
security which caused budgets to
skyrocket like this road from cost to
pack Tia
which cost almost five million dollars
per mile mostly because of security but
18 months later the time was up
President Obama announced that he'd
start bringing troops back after this
initial reduction our troops will
continue coming home at a steady pace
his Afghan security forces move into the
lead our mission will change from combat
to support as the u.s. troops withdrew
they left behind oversight of
infrastructure projects including roads
in 2012 USAID cut funding for road
construction and even after the US and
partnering countries spent three billion
dollars on it the Ring Road was never
completed Road building and maintenance
became the responsibility of the Afghan
government which was crippled by
corruption experts estimate that
billions of dollars have been lost to
corruption in Afghanistan
in 2015 with only about 11,000 US troops
in country mostly in the major cities
the Taliban swept back through
Afghanistan in 2017 they controlled
almost half the country that's more
territory than they've had since 2001
and that includes large sections of the
Ring Road and that's one of the reasons
why the road is in dire shape according
to a 2016 inspection 20% of the roads
are destroyed and 80% continued to
deteriorate the US has no plans to give
rebuilding Afghanistan a third chance
and 2017 president Trump committed more
troops but made it very clear we are not
nation-building again we are killing
terrorists as the Ring Road continues to
deteriorate it's no longer a symbol of
the u.s. efforts to rebuild Afghanistan
instead it serves as a reminder of the
job that was never finished
[Music]
[Music]